we're you on reading you may notice as
foodies GQ sent us around the country to
find the coolest bars and restaurants
here's your guide to Capitol Hill in
Seattle all the coolest spots we started
our night at bar naka we met up with
Nick and add a couple drinks and some
bites before we took off then we all
walked down the streets of our suit it's
sweet animal heads on the wall
I had a porchetta sandwich it had a
bunch of pork belly and some other good
it was pretty delicious you can also
drink here for pretty cheap if you're a
cheap bastard like me this is the place
you want to go after marsuit we started
walking through Capitol Hill Nick showed
us all the cool landmarks a really
unique stuff that makes the adil awesome
eventually we arrived at Cannon then an
insane amount of bottles so many bottles
it was crazy it was like a library of
bottles a liquid zoo if you will bottles
in the bathroom bottles in the basement
Nick ordered is a round of drinks and
the bartender was super cool he brought
some stuff out we drank it really good
let's play super highbrow but it also
felt like a neighborhood bar after we
left cannon Nick decided to take us to
rumba rumba is a really cool Pike Place
bar that only serves rum has one of the
world's largest selections of rums and
the bartender's made us some super-sweet
rum drinks Kessel gave us some rum shots
they also made some build your own Tiki
rum drinks rum rum rum I felt like a
goddamn pirate we picked up some people
that got married I think they're our
friends and Nick's I don't know but
they're pretty cool let's take them with
us
then we end up at unicorn and this place
is a total show it looks like a circus
and everything is really crazy
you have a much crazy drinks this is by
far the most eclectic Gaudi scary weird
place I've ever been to you if you're in
Seattle you have to stop here after
unicorn we got a couple overs Nick
wanted to take us to the bar we first
started bartending yet we ended up at
Liberty bar there's a little sushi bar
in the corner and the chef from naka had
a sushi battle everyone was cheering
this seemed like a real neighborhood
type place all the bartender's were
super fun we order a lot of drinks by
this time our group has grown to like 20
people it was really cool until the bill
came it was cool to end our night at
Liberty bar place with Nick first
started over off in Seattle is a pretty
awesome place there's a lot of
interesting bars to go to and every
neighborhood is completely different
user says your guide in Capitol Hill if
you're going to Seattle you gotta roll
here if you disagree tell us your
favorite spots